ahora vamos a trabajar con uno de mis
teoremas favoritos en matemáticas y ese
es el teorema del sándwich y una de las
razones por las cuales me gusta es
porque justo porque tiene la palabra
sándwich en su nombre que no es tan
común ver esto en matemáticas pero es un
nombre apropiado ok entonces vamos a
trabajar con el teorema teorema del
sándwich teorema del sándwich y que a
veces es bueno sobre todo por otros al
traducirlo de otros idiomas a veces
también se le conoce como el teorema de
la pep del apretón teorema del apretón y
verás que realmente son dos nombres muy
apropiados para lo que nos referimos con
este teorema y para para introducirnos a
la intuición de este teorema vamos a
pensar en una analogía y ver vamos a
vamos a ver a qué nos referimos entonces
digamos que tenemos tres personas
digamos que aquí está no sé que aquí
está alfredo ok aquí está alfredo
digamos que también tenemos a nuestra
sara y digamos también que está
guillermo que está guillermo aquí ok
entonces tengo estas tres personas y
tengo una una observación respecto de
ellas resulta que no importa qué día sea
siempre alfredo consume menos calorías
que zara y zara consumen menos calorías
que guillermo muy bien entonces vamos a
vamos a escribir esto digamos sara sara
come come al menos tanto como alfredo ok
entonces al menos tanto como alfredo eso
quiere decir que estará al menos con que
come al menos tanto como no come como
alfredo quiere decir que sara tiene un
consumo de calorías mayor o igual que
alfredo muy bien ahora bien vamos a
describir qué es lo que pasa con
guillermo guillermo
guillermo como guillermo come al menos
tanto como sara muy bien y esperemos que
este no sea mucho porque les puede hacer
daño a su salud pero esto pasa cualquier
día en cualquier día particular siempre
ocurre que guillermo come al menos tanto
como zara y zara come tanto al menos
como alfredo muy bien qué significa eso
en su consumo de calorías cada día
quiere decir que las calorías que
consume alfredo cada día que las
calorías de alfredo pues éstas van a
tener que ser algo más
es decir menores o iguales que las
calorías calorías de sara muy bien ahora
como como guillermo come al menos tanto
como comenzará entonces esto debe ser
menor o igual que el consumo de calorías
de guillermo cada día muy bien
muy bien ahí lo tenemos entonces
supongamos ok esto es la relación que
hay entre el consumo de calorías de
estos tres personajes ahora el detalle
es que supongamos que digamos un día
martes no sé quizás no sé un día martes
se ponen de acuerdo y alfredo alfredo
consume 1500 calorías muy bien digamos
que alfredo consume 1500 calorías y
digamos que guillermo también no comió
mucho ese día y guillermo consume 1500
calorías muy bien ese día estos dos
amigos consumen exactamente lo mismo que
es lo que va a pasar
resulta que el número de calorías que
consumen sara es mayor o igual que el
número de calorías que consume alfredo
eso es mayor o igual que 1500 muy bien
pero al mismo tiempo es menor o igual
que el número de calorías que consume
guillermo que son también 1500 así que
nos podemos preguntar cuántas o cuales
es el número que está por arriba de 1500
y por abajo de 1500 y entonces llegamos
a la asombrosa conclusión de que sarah
consume 1500 calorías verdad es el único
número que está por arriba de 1500 y por
abajo de 1500 verdad
que está que es mayor o igual que 1500 y
menor o igual que 1500 muy bien entonces
el teorema del sándwich que vamos a ver
es la versión digamos para funciones de
este mismo ejemplo muy bien vamos a
pensar por ejemplo que las calorías el
número de calorías que consumen cada uno
son funciones que dependen del día muy
bien entonces voy a borrar todo esto y
vamos y lo voy a borrar justo para
ponerme un poquito más matemático y
poder trabajar con ello sale entonces sí
es importante que tengas muy en mente
este ejemplo porque vamos a hacer
exactamente lo mismo pero para funciones
entonces digamos que tengo yo una
función
efe de x f x que justamente va a ser
como las calorías que consume alfredo va
a ser menor o igual kg de x muy bien
donde pueden ser las calorías que
consumen sara y esto es menor o igual
que hdx que son las calorías digamos que
consume guillermo muy bien entonces para
ver esto más
vamos a poner lo digamos dibujado en una
gráfica
ahí tienen ustedes el eje y este es el
eje y y vamos a poner el eje x ahí lo
tienen muy bien entonces si pintamos una
f más bien primero pintamos la que está
por arriba de las dos digamos que esta
es nuestra hdx
ok ahí tienen la gráfica de hdx y vamos
a pintar ahora la gráfica fx no sé
digamos que hace algo muy extraño por
aquí
oops déjenme ponerlo con el mismo color
digamos que hace algo así de repente
puede estar por aquí
muy bien ahí está la gráfica de fx ahora
si nosotros queremos pintarla de gx está
por supuesto siempre debe estar entre la
roja y la azul verdad entonces aquí
tenemos que la gráfica de eje x tiene
que verse más o menos algo así muy bien
entonces aquí está dibujado justamente
lo que nos dice esta relación y bueno
esto lo podríamos pensar quizás sólo en
un intervalo no necesariamente tiene que
ser en toda la recta pero aquí queda muy
clara la idea ahora vamos a suponer lo
siguiente para este punto
digamos existe un punto ce algún punto
ce tal que la roja y la azul son
idénticas se van pareciendo
idénticamente en ese punto
digamos que valen l y ahora cuando digo
valen en realidad estoy pensando en lo
siguiente que el límite cuando x se
aproxima hace de nuestra función
f x
será igual a un valor l y que también el
límite cuando x se aproxima hace de
nuestra función hdx tiene el mismo valor
ahora puede que estas funciones h y f no
estén definidas en ce lo que importa es
que el límite exista a medida que nos
aproximamos hace muy bien entonces lo
que nos dice el teorema del sándwich y
que por eso se llama el teorema del
sándwich puedes pensar que la función f
es como la tapa inferior de un sándwich
y la función h es la tapa superior de un
sándwich muy bien entonces qué pasa con
la g de x la gtx qué pasa cuando nos
aproximamos a c es decir que ocurre con
el límite cuando x tiende hace de
nuestra función g x muy bien y
justamente aquí está esta imagen nos
está diciendo todo verdad estas dos
cosas van a implicar que el límite de
esta función de x exista y sea también l
muy bien entonces tú dirás hoy esta es
una cosa como de sentido común vas
el dibujo para qué es esto útil y en
realidad es muy práctico para calcular
algunos límites donde podrías poner una
función quizás muy extraña entre dos que
si conoces y así poder digamos ponerlo
en medio del sándwich y saber cuál es el
valor del límite que nos interese